so I want to say some things about
suicide today it's a difficult subject a
painful subject a personal subject
like so many millions of other people
this is something that I have not only
heard about on the news but I've also
encountered in around me in my own life
in the lives of people close to me
especially and I think that's probably
the case for almost everybody that's
watching us right now almost everybody
unfortunately in the countries probably
connected to this issue personally in
some way you know so that's what I want
to talk about and and the reason I want
to tell you ahead of time that this is
something that I have encountered is so
that you understand that you know I'm
not just approaching this from a purely
analytical kind of detached perspective
but from a from I I hope Rennell and
grounded perspective but also a human
one a personal one
now obviously the reason that we're
discussing this now is that two
prominent people killed themselves
last week Anthony Bourdain and and Kate
Spade and in the meantime there have
been news reports about the the rapidly
rising suicide rate across the country
and it's rising nearly everywhere in
every state so something is clearly
happening in this country
something something is going wrong I
think that's obvious and when we see
suicide especially among the rich and
famous and successful it makes us stop
and kind of ponder for a minute because
our assumptions are overturned and the
facade kind of melts away and we're
awakened to this or reawakened I guess
to this stark reality where we realized
that wealth and comfort and success are
just frills they're they're superficial
they don't they don't mean anything
necessarily because a person can have
all that and yet be deeply in despair
they can be hopeless and miserable and
yet have all that
so there has to be more to life we
realize
we you know we often will look at rich
and famous people and we'll say man they
must really love their lives right we'll
look at somebody
it was like that and we'll say man you
must really love his life but what do we
mean when we say that
what we really mean is that they must
love the comforts and luxuries in their
lives but to love comfort and luxury is
not to love life to love life is to love
life regardless of the circumstances so
if we can't love life in poverty if we
can't love it in suffering if we can't
love it while deprived and wanting and
hungry and all of that then we don't
love it and so for those of us who can't
even imagine loving life under those
circumstances and our affection for life
is tied completely to either the the
material goods that we have or the
material goods that we dream of one day
accumulating for those of us in that in
that category we we don't love life and
we are either in despair or we're on the
edge of despair and so I think that
there are
a great many people in this country who
are either in despair or are on the edge
of it and our reaction to the suicides
of famous successful people just kind of
speaks to this yeah of course we should
be sad of course it's you know of course
we're going to be surprised
the fact that we're shocked at the very
idea that someone who is rich and famous
might kill themselves that I think that
reveals a something within ourselves we
have a a misunderstanding about life and
about what's supposed to make people
happy so even with all of these facts
and these things
tragically demonstrated to us by the
suicides of people like Anthony Bourdain
and Kate Spade I think we continue in
the face of this issue we continue to
miss the point of everything
continue to pet to perpetuate the
problem by reacting to suicide in the
worst possible ways and saying the worst
possible things about it and so I want
to focus today especially on two
mistakes that I think we make when we
talk about suicide and I think these are
dangerous mistakes these are mistakes
that are leading people down very dark
paths
so the first mistake I've heard time and
time again especially after the suicide
of somebody things
that suicide is not a choice
this is what people will say they say
well it's not a choice nobody would
choose that
this I think this is basically
well-intentioned when people say this
that they're trying to be generous to
the departed they don't want to suggest
that somebody would actually choose this
because if they chose it then that means
that they also chose to leave their
families and to leave the whole world
behind and to cause all this pain and
suffering to those around them and and
we don't want to say that because if we
say that then that means that we're
saying that suicide is selfish and which
is which is something that by the way in
the old days was generally accepted by
everyone that it's a selfish act but now
you're not allowed to say that you don't
we don't want to say that because it's
very mean to say so instead we go all
the way to the other extreme and we
completely exonerate the person who's
committed suicide we completely not only
exonerate them but we defend we
practically defend what they did by
saying that it wasn't a choice it was
merely the result of depression and
death is the result of depression like
death may be the result of pancreatic
cancer we said it's just something you
can't help it you you have new play no
part in it whatsoever
it just happens to you that's all in the
same way that if you have cancer and
your organs start shutting down and
we'll have it it's it's it's exactly the
same this is what I've been told it's
exactly the same there's no difference
and when a person commits suicide from
depression they play no purposeful role
in it at all
what a horrible
thing to say
it is absolutely the worst thing to say
I mean it really is horrible and if this
is the kind of thing that you say in the
wake of you know suicide being in the
news I ask you to stop saying that
because it's wrong
it's a lie and you're hurting people it
is a horrible terrible awful thing to
say
to say that it's not a choice at all is
a horrible thing
it's not hard to see why it would be so
horrible and dangerous
about it for a second
imagine a suicidal person imagine a
suicidal person who is depressed lost
and hopeless he already feels like he
has no choice like there is no other way
he feels that way it doesn't mean that
that's actually what's going on it
doesn't mean that it's true but he feels
that way and then you come along
and confirm this notion
you come along and say you're right you
have no choice depression just may up
and kill you one day against your will
you have no choice in the matter there's
nothing you can do of your own volition
you have no choice
what have you done in the interest of
being fair
generous to the dead what have you done
to the living
maybe we should focus more when we talk
about suicide we should focus more on
helping the living
and the dead tragically terribly
the people who are dead are now there's
there's there's
they're gone now
but there are people there's a lot of
people that are still alive we're
struggling with this
and so when we tell these lies about
suicide for the sake of the dead we hurt
the living
and so what have you done to this
depressed person who's on the edge of
being suicidal or is suicidal yet is
still alive
by telling him he has no choice what
have you done you've done the opposite
of empower him you've done the opposite
of of encourage him you've just told him
he has no power he has no free will
you've just told him depression his
disease like cancer it's a cancer inside
him there's nothing he can do about it
at all it may kill him against his will
do you really not see the problem with
saying that to somebody
do you think when somebody is is
suicidal what they need to be told is
they have no choice
now let's imagine this a little bit more
directly and explicitly imagine that a
man is standing at the top of a building
on the ledge okay and you're standing
there 30 feet away on the top of the
building
he shouts to you and he says I have no
choice I have to do it there's no other
way what do you say in response
do you say you're right you have no
choice you're not guilty this is not you
should have no guilt this is not a
choice you have no choice this is a
disease doing this to you nobody will
judge you if you go ahead with it you
have no choice is that what you say
or do you say you do have a choice
yes you do have a choice you have the
power you are in control this is all you
right now and you will decide what the
next step is
and there is a right and wrong choice
here you have the power to make the
right choice you do now I would suggest
that if you
if you said the first thing
no choice to somebody on the edge of a
building you are a monster
you you're you're just a monster
you're like that what was the case of
that girl
who
who was who encouraged basically
encouraged her boyfriend to commit
suicide and while he was in the car
about to go through with the act
she was text messaging him basically
saying but yeah you know this is the
only way just go ahead and do it
that's what it reminds me
if you would actually say that to
somebody on the ledge of a building but
you would never say that you would never
say that to somebody on the on the edge
of a building would you you would never
say it in that situation to somebody on
the physical ledge
so why do so many people say it to those
who are almost on the ledge if you
wouldn't say it to the person while
they're on the ledge about to jump why
would you say it to all the people in
our society who are metaphorically right
now walking towards that ledge why would
you take power and choice away from them
at the moment when they most need it and
most need to realize that they have it
now of course it's true that a suicidal
person is compromised intellectually
emotionally he's burdened he's in pain
all of these things the emotional
turmoil the despair the storm that's
raging inside them these are all
mitigating factors when assessing the
personal guilt of the person after the
Act but here's the thing we are not the
ones who assess the personal guilt after
the fact that's God that's not our job
he's gonna sort that out we can't we
can't go anywhere near that subject so
it's true that all these things that the
what's going on inside somebody's head
and heart when they make this decision
or when they make any decision that
speaks to their personal moral moral
guilt and it can seriously it would seem
mitigate that guilt but again that's not
what we're talking abut we're not
assessing guilt
we can't assign guilt neither can we
take guilt away we can't just sit back
and announce that oh this person is
entirely guilty for this act and we also
can't sit back and say they're not
guilty at all we can we can't say either
one of those things and to say either
one of those things would be a terrible
lie it would also be to put ourselves in
the place of God which we can't do all
we can do is determine what is literally
physically true
does a person choose to act a certain
way or not
how much guilt they personally carry
with them for choosing it that's not we
can't do that but did they choose it
I mean you know I pick up this cup am i
choosing to do this you can't get inside
my mind and and tell me anything about
what's going on inside my heart or my
mind but I certainly am obviously
choosing to do this because nobody else
is doing it I am physically doing it I
am choosing to do it we have free will
and a choice that is made under great
duress is still a choice
a decision made in despair in pain is
still a decision
if somebody came into the room right now
and put a gun to my head and said Matt
pick up that Cup
you know something I still have a choice
I could refuse to pick it up now the
consequences would be very severe I'd
probably be killed but I could choose
not to do it so even with a literal gun
to my head my free will and my capacity
to choose are still intact nobody can
take that away I still have it
you
to say that to say that suicide is not a
choice is either to say that every
person who commits suicide is clinically
insane
or which would be a ridiculous claim
obviously or it's the kind of
compartmentalize a person's mind and to
say okay well here is you on one hand
inside your mind and then over here this
is the part of your brain that commit
suicide and that part is not you that's
not you this is you that's not what does
that mean if that's not you who is it
of course it's you they're both you you
you are a complete whole person you
can't be divided up you are a complete
whole immutable human being and that you
can't be divided into sections it's only
you you are the only one who is you the
fact that you're under duress when you
make a wrong choice does not mean that
it wasn't a choice Oh
every destructive choice
is made under either some kind of duress
or in response to a compulsion or a
temptation every destructive choice is
made that way and the really destructive
choices the really bad choices are
always made under severe duress or in
response to severe compulsion so think
about think about the worst crimes that
you can imagine think about any people
that are in jail for the worst kinds of
crimes rape murder so on nobody does
those things while in a calm state of
mind they're always in some kind of
turmoil and internally there's always a
compulsion of course there is so if
suicide is is not a choice then no bad
thing is a choice if we only have free
will
when we're also free from compulsion and
emotional stress then nobody has free
will and if that's what you believe that
nobody has free will then so be it but
please then you have to explain if you
don't believe that anyone has free will
well then what are you doing passing out
the suicide hotline what are you doing
saying you know if you're depressed if
you feel suicidal talk to somebody
what are you doing passing out hotlines
and giving tips to depressed people if
you don't think they have a choice if
you don't think they can choose to act
upon the advice you are giving them then
why are you giving it
the fact that you're giving advice means
that you know it's a choice that they
have a choice and so you're trying to
influence them to make the right choice
which is a wonderful thing to do all I'm
saying is don't confuse the situation by
saying that on one hand on the on the
other hand saying well they don't have a
choice
you
it is a choice in a literal sense it is
a choice
and so we asked ourselves
what is true is it a choice or is it not
well it's true that it is a choice
so ask yourself what is the most helpful
thing to say to someone who's
contemplating suicide is it helpful to
tell them that they have no choice or is
it helpful to tell them that they do I
think clearly it's most helpful to tell
them that they do
this is not about heaping guilt it's not
about telling you no it's not about
anything like that it's about empowering
telling the truth and it's about
empowering
and if person is contemplating this act
and they think about that the fact that
they have a choice and that they have
the power and which isn't to say that
this is something they should do on
their own
no because if you're in that state of
mind you need to reach out and talk to
somebody get some help I agree with that
don't go through it on your own the fact
that you have a choice doesn't mean that
there's something you have to do on your
own or should the one you're on you
shouldn't
when we get to that point we have to
reach out for help but that doesn't but
that's not the same thing as saying you
have no choice because again if you have
no choice then you can't even reach out
to anybody
necessarily you can't choose to do that
okay so the second mistake people make
I have seen many people say again this
is basically well-intentioned but
harmful and foolish many people have
said that that Anthony Bourdain and Kate
Spade are finally at peace this is what
I've seen online they're finally at
peace
and this brings to mind that tweet that
the Academy sent after Robin Williams
committed suicide maybe you remember the
tweet was a picture of Aladdin hugging
the genie the genie which of course was
voiced by Robin Williams and the caption
said genie you're free
now these are nice sentiments they are
pleasant sentiments
they're also horrible
now again we're not God we cannot know
what happens to any individual person
after death
we can't know
it would certainly be wrong to declare
that every suicide is now in hell very
few people are tempted to make such
declarations these days so it's not even
worth dwelling on but if anyone were to
say that it would be wrong to say
because you're not God you you don't
decide that you cannot assess personal
moral guilt you don't know what was
going on inside somebody's heart inside
their mine so that's why whether it's a
suicide or no matter how no matter how
somebody dies and under no matter under
what circumstances they die you cannot
say where they are and what they're
doing right now
but
it's wrong to say because it's up to God
to decide it only god can judge what's
happening inside somebody's heart and
soul
God can judge you know that's what
everyone says only guy can judge but
what what what people really mean when
they say that is that only god can judge
the guilt or innocence of a person we
can however judge actions we have been
given that ability by God and he wants
us to use that ability so we can judge
the action of suicide
as gravely wrong deeply disordered and
thus not a means to peace or freedom
so it's it's wrong to say of an
individual person who died from suicide
that they're in hell it's very wrong to
say but it is certainly wrong I would
say even more wrong because of the
scandal that it causes and what it may
encourage people to do I would say it's
even more wrong to sit back and just
declare oh they're at peace now they're
happy now they're at peace they're not
suffering anymore they're at peace
um
the truth is we don't know where they
are
it's happening to them or how much piece
they they have or don't have
what we do know is that the act of
suicide is extremely wrong and extremely
bad and anyone who is looking for peace
and freedom should not look for it that
way
that's what we know and that's what we
should say
now again think of the suicidal person
do you imagine that you're helping him
by saying that Anthony Bourdain is at
peace and free right now
if you mean to help him over the ledge
well then that's a great way to do it
but if you mean to dissuade him from
self annihilation you are doing it wrong
because very clearly clearly you are
promoting and glorifying suicide and
making it seem appealing when you speak
about it in those kinds of terms
when a suicidal person hears you say oh
this person killed themselves they're at
peace now clearly you are promoting it
to that person you are directly you are
like selling it to them
you
so please stop saying that
it's not true you don't you you you you
cannot speak for the for the state of
somebody's soul after death this is a
wrong thing it's a bad thing
it's a it's it's a it's it's it's it's
not a good thing to do which is why we
try to persuade people not to do it and
so we can't go around saying that this
is how people find peace this is not how
you find peace
you
one more point about this
we seem so concerned with some with
protecting the honor
and the good name of those who have
already died this way
but what about the families that are
left behind
how would you like it if somebody close
to you killed themselves say your spouse
or something and you are left
justifiably angry justifiably feeling
abandoned
but then
one comes up to you and says of that
person who just left you oh he's at
peace now
he's uh he's free he had no choice he
had no choice you know
what they're telling you is that your
anger is unfair and that your feelings
are off-base and in fact you are the
selfish one apparently because you would
prefer if your loved one didn't find his
piece you you're feeling angry and
abandoned and what you're being told by
all these people is you you have no
right to feel that way
that's that's that's wrong it's you what
you didn't want this person to find
their peace
again I think this is just wrong I think
it's it's so wrong
I think that our our rhetoric around
suicide needs to be focused on the
living
more than its focused on you no more
than being focused on trying to justify
and so on after the fact
it needs to be focused on promoting life
and on and and on and on taking into
consideration those who are alive our
job after a suicide is not to protect
the honor and good name of a person
who's already committed suicide it's to
say the truth for the sake of those who
are contemplating it and for the sake of
those who have been left behind because
of it
that's what we need to do
obviously I don't think we should insult
or demean a person who kills themselves
far from it but neither should we say
untruths and lies for their sake it's
not right it's dangerous it's hurting
people
we need to step back and look at the
situation and see that yes our rhetoric
around suicide our discussion around
suicide now is just so it's it's to call
it non-judgmental is is underselling it
completely
suicides gotten to the point where it it
basically promotes it and and an
outright justifies it
and what have we seen happen at the same
time the suicide rate just climbs and
climbs and climbs I don't think that's a
coincidence
so these are just some things that take
in consideration
and again I will say just in closing but
struggling with feelings like this and
thoughts like this
make the choice to talk to somebody and
to reach out for help
because we're not meant to suffer
through the darkest
moments alone
it's a very hard thing to be alone and
to think you're alone and we don't need
to be you're not
alright thanks for watching everybody
thank you for listening Godspeed
you